[Music]
this episode and others like it are made
possible by the generous support of my
patrons on patreon
if you'd like to help me produce more
content like this consider becoming a
patron at patreon.com
second thought and get early access to
every new episode
when you think about what defines the
united states what comes to mind
big cars big flags mcdonald's probably
all the stereotypical stuff but i'd be
willing to bet that for most people
outside the u.s
one of the first things that comes to
mind is our incredibly massive and
powerful military and that's no surprise
with over 600 military bases in other
countries and a near-constant armed
occupation of various regions
it makes sense that the only experience
many people have with the us is our
military presence
despite what u.s news sources would have
you believe our military is not a
welcome sight in much of the world
far too often the site of u.s fatigues
means imminent death
often for unarmed innocent people but
over the years
a new type of armed american has started
appearing in u.s occupied regions
and these people are even less
accountable than the us military
in this episode we're going to talk
about private military companies
the recent blackwater pardons and how
these mercenary groups fit into the u.s
imperialist framework
we all have a good sense of what the u.s
military looks like
with a larger budget than the next 10
nations combined we have more planes
ships helicopters and armored vehicles
than we know what to do with
but what exactly is a private military
company these companies pmcs for short
are private companies providing armed
combat or security services for
financial gain
the operatives known as contractors who
are employed by these companies
are often hired as protection for
notable figures armed security for u.s
corporations in unreceptive regions
and for covert missions at the behest of
the us government
of course contractors who use military
force in a war zone are considered
unlawful combatants by the geneva
convention
but as you can imagine we tend to ignore
the rules that the rest of the world has
to follow
uspmcs have operated in over 50
countries and on every continent except
antarctica
back in the 90s there used to be 50
military personnel for every one private
contractor
today the ratio is 10 to 1. considering
the u.s is home to over 1.3 million
active duty personnel
that means there are somewhere around
130 000
armed americans committing acts of
violence in regions around the world at
the direction of u.s corporations
wealthy individuals and intelligence
groups we'll get to the significance of
this fact a bit later
but first let's consider the recent
presidential pardon of four black water
contractors for crimes they committed
during the u.s occupation of iraq
blackwater now known as academy was
founded in 1997 by former navy seal eric
prince
who is coincidentally the brother of
trump's education secretary betsy devos
blackwater started out as a shooting
range and training facility for the
armed services police and security
personnel
but after the invasion of iraq became an
active and lucrative private military
company since 2003 the company has
received billions of dollars in
contracts from the u.s state department
the military and the cia for work
they've done in iraq and afghanistan
which has run the gamut from protecting
various dignitaries to securing oil
fields to mercenary violence
but what really put blackwater on the
average american's radar is the atrocity
committed by four of their contractors
in september of 2007.
i was on a bus when the shooting started
heavy fire came towards us
i felt the first bullet hit my leg as i
scrambled off
i kept running towards the bus station
then i got hit again
when i stopped i was hit a third time i
felt like the bones in my leg had
exploded
i fell down and started to crawl there
was utter chaos
people were terrified trying to save
themselves
this video was filmed after the attack
14 iraqis including two children were
killed
and at least 20 others injured one
heavily armed convoy of contractors with
the american security company blackwater
opened fire at a busy intersection in
the capital baghdad
just before noon on september 16 2007
a team of black water contractors
operating under the call sign raven 23
opened fire in a traffic circle in
baghdad according to their official
statement their vehicles had taken fire
and one of them had been disabled
at which point the blackwater operatives
started shooting at everyone around them
eyewitness accounts and a u.s court of
law determined this to be a lie
the contractors murdered 17 people that
day and wounded 20 more
14 civilians died on the scene two of
whom were young children
just 9 and 11 years old according to
people in the square that day
and to later evidence compiled by the
fbi the americans had not been provoked
and had simply decided to kill innocent
civilians
one military officer commented on the
massacre saying it was obviously
excessive
the civilians that were fired upon they
didn't have any weapons to fire back at
them
and none of the iraqi police or any of
the local security forces fired back at
them
despite all this the men continued to
shoot including at cars that were
turning to get away
even though the evidence of this heinous
crime was apparent from the beginning
it took years for the murderers to be
convicted in october of 2014
over seven years after the massacre four
men were finally prosecuted for their
actions
nick slatten the sniper who first opened
fire was sentenced to life in prison
while three other men dustin hurd evan
liberty and paul sloth received 30 years
later reduced to 12 to 15 years each
then on december 22
2020 president trump granted a full
pardon to each of the four men
citing quote a long history of service
to the nation the response among the
victims families and the general public
has been rightly critical
when i heard about trump's decision i
was shocked and disappointed
we are the victims and those men are the
murderers i thought the u.s justice
system was independent but it seems
justice is affected by u.s politics
the iraqi foreign ministry quickly
reacting saying the president's pardons
ignored the dignity of the victims and
the feelings and rights of their
families
many iraqis have long felt the incident
showed
americans did not value iraqi lives
at least 14 civilians lost their lives
that day
the youngest nine-year-old ali shot in
the head in the back seat of the car
as his father helplessly watched him die
my son was the heart of our family
muhammad abdul razak says
another person who we spoke to was
pleading with president trump
to not release these men to not allow
them to go free because he said they
were the ones who were terrorists
there's a lot of shock today in iraq and
in fact
beyond because of what has just taken
place a lot of as you heard in barbara's
package there
people being reminded of something that
they have felt for a
very very long time and that is that
americans they really just don't value
iraqi life
then of course you've got fox news
giving full-throated support to the
pardons
what the president did for those black
water contractors it's been described as
a
massacre what it was is the fog of a
moment where they were doing their job
to protect state department employees in
one of the most dangerous parts of
baghdad at one of the most dangerous
moments
a lot of the evidence totally
mischaracterized mishandled by iraqis
many of which had ties to insurgents
they were tried in a civilian court
which has no connection
uh to what it's like to be in that war
they volunteered to be there
and a huge credit to the
commander-in-chief who there's no upside
to a call like this other than
sending a signal to our war fighters
whether you're a contractor in uniform
we're gonna have your back when you make
tough calls on the battlefield much like
some of the pardons he gave
uh for other members of the military
before so kudos
uh from my perspective to the president
for doing what he did
for those black water i don't know pete
maybe these guys were charged
in a civilian court because they're
civilians they're not military personnel
they're cosplaying as special forces
while getting to operate completely
outside the regulations of the military
of course we can all expect this kind of
behavior from fox news
but what's more disappointing is the
reaction to the pardon by the pastor of
one of the blackwater thugs
that's that's the kind of stuff that uh
sweet
um christmas movies are made of honey
he's been pardoned
free pardon totally full parted he's
home
just just a sense of joy of knowing um
that these the children are going to be
with their dad
the complete lack of recognition of the
cruelty of this statement is shocking
the kids will have their dad back
imagine the families of the victims
hearing that and seeing that footage
knowing they will never get their loved
ones back specifically because of this
man
he thought everybody was okay that they
had lived through a miracle
when one of the cousins in the back seat
said that ali was hurt
muhammad got out of the car opened the
door went to the back seat
saw blood on the inside of the window
and ali slumped over against the glass
he opened the door
and this is a bit graphic but what
happened was ali
slumped towards muhammad his skull was
open
and a portion of his brain fell out onto
the pavement in the source square
forgiveness is admirable but that's not
what this is
this is blind support of us brutality
and it's wrong
so yes what the president did was
reprehensible
these four people massacred innocent men
women and children
and will now walk away scot-free but
here's the thing
trump is just a convenient scapegoat in
this situation take cnn for example
they jumped at the chance to slam trump
for his pardons as was justified
but they're also counting on the fact
that we've forgotten that they were some
of the loudest proponents of the war in
iraq
their fear-mongering and that of the
other big networks played a major role
in allowing atrocities like the
blackwater massacre to happen
the media's job is to manufacture
consent for the country's need to be
constantly embroiled in low-level wars
the u.s needs enemies to justify our
absurd military spending
including the hundreds of billions of
dollars we spend on pmcs
and they won't have that justification
unless we have a population of people
force-fed pro-war news 24 hours a day on
every major network
after the second world war news coverage
of the soviet union immediately became
hostile
everything they did was considered a
threat to the american way of life
our only goal became beating the dirty
communists that red scare propaganda has
seeped so deeply into our national
consciousness that it's still a problem
to this day
but that's a topic for another video
fast forward to the fall of the soviet
union
and the u.s had a problem on their hands
our big enemy had been defeated
capitalism now reigns supreme what
happened next we entered a decade of
malaise among the general public
with the u.s frantically trying to get
us involved in new wars to fuel the
all-consuming military-industrial
complex
2001 comes along and suddenly we've got
our answer
an attack on u.s soil is just what the
nation needed to spark the bloodlust
again
and the networks ran with it but this
time they were more sophisticated
instead of naming a single enemy we
branded this new conflict the war on
terror so we could finish meddling in
one country and say
look there's some terror over there and
invade an entirely different country
fast forward nearly 20 years and here we
are a country of people who are finally
fed up with war in the middle east
it's old news public support for
military action in the region is at
record lows
but look what's that on the horizon it's
china they're communist
remember the communists and how bad they
are if you turn on the tv today and
watch any news coverage of china you'll
notice one thing
it's all negative all of it every single
action china takes is considered
military posturing against the united
states
why because like the soviet union china
represents a rising challenger to u.s
economic domination
it has nothing to do with china
threatening to go to war with us
they've made no indication that war is
even remotely enticing
but that doesn't matter when we have
news networks that can spin the
narrative to make any country seem like
an existential threat
okay but how does all this relate to
private military companies
well consider how the nature of war has
evolved over the decades
we've gone from massive troop
deployments to remote strikes from miles
away
we have less and less need for large
numbers of soldiers to enforce the
nation's will on other countries
the number of private contractors has
increased dramatically since the 90s and
their use has skyrocketed among
corporate and government entities alike
the reasoning is simple why rely on the
official government arm of us
imperialism when we can outsource our
crimes against humanity to a third party
thereby granting ourselves another level
of plausible deniability against all
accusations
we didn't overthrow your local
government and install a puppet leader
it was that pmc over there
the pmc gets shut down the people behind
the operation rebrand themselves with a
new name and legal documents and they're
back in the game
as we saw with blackwater's massacre in
2007
it's incredibly difficult to prosecute
pmcs because the nature of their work is
inherently secretive and conducted in
other countries with very little
oversight
private military companies are nothing
more than a convenient way to pursue
violent imperialist goals without
dirtying the hands of the us military
money that would have been spent on the
military is more and more often being
diverted to fund private groups of armed
thugs and murderers
often veterans of the armed services who
have demonstrated a capability for
incredible
cruelty this is the future of warfare a
hands-off approach from the official
branches of the military with a heavy
investment in more secretive more
violent
and less accountable paramilitary groups
these groups not only enable state
violence
but also allow u.s corporations
operating overseas to pursue their own
violent forms of suppression of
competition or resistance
so yes you should be angry that the
president pardoned war criminals instead
of whistleblowers like assange or
snowden
but realize that all of this fits the
theme of american imperialism perfectly
revealing the wrongdoing of the state is
treason but committing the very crimes
that whistleblowers have revealed is
service to the nation
the media gets to criticize trump for
doing a thing that is objectively bad
while downplaying their own role in
facilitating our violence against these
victims and millions more around the
world
the pardons send a message to other pmcs
that they can operate with impunity
that no matter what they do they'll get
away with it we should expect to see a
continued expansion of paramilitary
action in u.s occupied regions
it checks all the boxes plausible
deniability outsourcing of labor
profitability and a furthering of u.s
imperialist goals
i mentioned at the beginning of this
video that this kind of content is
supported by my patrons on patreon
this type of video while very important
is something that sponsors won't touch
in order to pay the bills and keep this
channel running i rely on adsense
revenue
sponsors and donations from generous
viewers by producing explicitly
anti-capitalist content
i lose out on both sponsors and adsense
if you enjoy the kind of videos i'm
producing and you're able to chip in
even a dollar a month i would greatly
appreciate the support
you can find my patreon page and join
our growing discord server at
patreon.com
second thought if you enjoyed this video
consider dropping a like
if you hated it a thumbs down you can
check out my previous episodes by
clicking the links on your screen
thanks for watching and i'll see you
next week
you